[Music]
imagine you're an economic student
and it's the start of the academic year
you're sitting in one of these chairs
in the lecture venue and your lecturer
is talking about
changes in unemployment rates and
productivity
and brings up this graph from your
economics textbook
showing the trends and change over time
well having just lived through 2020
you likely know someone or know someone
who knows someone
who lost their job due to the covert
pandemic
and your eyes immediately avert to this
part of the graph
what's going on here what would this
graph look like
if we could include more recent data
wouldn't it be great if your lecturer
could draw on a relevant
recent experience to make the teaching
more engaging and also have the textbook
resources to support this
the problem is this figure from an
economics textbook
was manually produced in proprietary
software
where each element was individually
placed by a designer according to their
style sheet
it is very time intensive and expensive
updating and reproducing figures such as
this
is one of the key contributing factors
to the really slow revision cycles
of such a textbook
our world is rapidly advancing and
changing
and although we may have the data
available our educational resources
quickly become outdated and likely stay
so for several years
this is not a problem that is only
common to the educational publishing
industry
how can we invigorate such a traditional
process
to overcome this my name is megan
beckett
i'm a data scientist from cape town
south africa and i'd like to tell you
about how we
at exegetic analytics partnered with
a publishing company in order to
prototype a pipeline
to automatically produce figures for an
economics textbook
there are thousands of these images and
each has been meticulously
manually handmade by the designers
according to their style sheet
the first question the publishing house
came to me with was
can you automate this so that we can
easily update them
well with r and the tidy verse of course
we can
the first step in the process was
therefore to figure out
an automated pipeline we started out
with the data
in excel files and various other sources
which were ingested
into google sheets as a central
repository
the reason for using google sheets
instead of
a database was that we still wanted it
to be easily accessible to non-technical
users
so they could also access the data and
update it as needed
each figure is then governed by a
central r script
where the data is read in the figure
produced in ggplot
and then the main output focus was svg
however with such an automated workflow
we can also output multiple formats
useful in their various publishing
platforms whether it's epub print or the
web
furthermore by taking advantage of the
plutly library
and adding a single line of code to our
scripts we can also create
interactive versions of each figure
for the web further enhancing the
teaching and learning experience
this entire process is wrapped up within
our package
with several helper functions to help
automate this pipeline
when we get to integrating with the
publishing houses
processes this will likely become an api
so we tick the box of figuring out how
to automate
this pipeline so the graphs can be
easily updated
but the next question they came with was
well
can you make them look as good as our
originals
as publishers it was very important to
them that the figures looked good for
teaching
that they complied to their style
guidelines and that they were virtually
indistinguishable from the originals
the second part of the project therefore
focused on the aesthetics
and this is where gigi plot really came
to the party
and it's also a part of the project that
i thoroughly enjoyed
on the left hand side here you can see
an example piece
from the style sheet that the designers
worked with in order to produce the
figures
this needed to be translated into code
the vast majority of the aesthetics of
the figures was controlled with
a custom ggplot theme here i've shown a
simplified version
on the right hand side to demonstrate
what i'm talking about
we started out with the base
classic theme and then built upon that
where each specification in the visual
style sheet was translated into code
as a specification to the theme for
example the font families
the point sizes colors and lines and
even the spacing around
all of the elements it really is quite
incredible
how much you can control the output of
your gt plot figures
i'd like to show you some of the outputs
of what we achieved
on the left hand side you can see the
original meticulously manual plot
the purpose here is not to read and
understand these graphs but rather to
make a comparison
between this and the aesthetically
automated
this here is our example from the
beginning from the economics lecture
with an additional plot below if you do
spot any differences
please do tweet me as i do really love
doing this
here is a second example and what i want
to point out here
are some deliberate differences you
might have noticed this in the previous
graph as well
but there are some dotted lines blue
lines
that show the trends for different time
periods
when i calculated these trends from the
data and plotted them on the graph
i noticed a stark difference
particularly for the 18th century
as indicated here when i realized then
is that the designer had visually looked
at the data
and placed the trend line by hand
according to what they thought was best
this is very error prone so
not only is our plot on the right
aesthetically automated
but it is also more accurate than the
original
as it is derived directly from the data
this third example was really quite a
fun challenge to solve
specifically around the layout and how
we placed
these dotted gray lines extending from
points
on the top graph to corresponding points
on the bottom graph
as i mentioned about eighty percent of
the aesthetics of the plots
was achieved with the ggplot theme
however here i also used the grid extra
and gg text and gg and g-table
packages which really power
the layout engine of ggplot
i was able to get into the underlying
grubs and grid
in order to produce such a layout i
really was
quite proud of this image
this last example here shows some
trendlines for different cities
what i want you to take note of though
are the icons used in the legend
called key gloves these are not standard
key glitz that come with gt plots
typically each geom has an associated
function
that will draw the key glyphs in the
legend if it's required
so for example geom point has a keyglove
function
called draw underscore key and score
point
that will then add points to the legend
as icons
if needed so what we did was look at the
gg plot code
for how these keegler functions work and
create some of our own custom functions
to manually draw these
icons so for example this one is a key
path
with a key symbol placed on the right
hand side of that path
to obtain this icon these key glyph
functions
are then passed to
the jam layer within the ggplot
code so that we can manually
so that we can update these key legends
accordingly
to how the original looks
having done this the publishing house
were now
quite impressed with our skills
inspiring to believe in us that we could
actually do this
the next question then was okay so can
you do this
in all languages this economics textbook
has been translated into several
languages
and so we needed to figure out how to
handle the automatic
translation of these figures in our
pipeline
this third step therefore focused on
translation
and the solution that we came up with
was to
capture the translated strings in the
yaml file
which is then read into the r script for
the figure
yaml if you're not familiar with it used
to stand for yes another markup language
and it's now become the recursive
acronym yaml 8 markup language
to specifically distinguish its use as
being data oriented
rather than a traditional markup for
documents
it's often used in configuration files
and you might have seen it
or noticed it at the top of our markdown
documents
that's yamo it's very structured
and importantly it's human readable
this is important for us because we
needed the translators who are
non-technical
to be able to easily work with the
format in order to capture their
translated strings
but at the same time i have a structure
that has a clear format to it and it's
data oriented to work within r
on the left hand side here you can see
an example from one of our
yaml files each of the languages is
denoted by
an abbreviated two-letter word for
example
en for english each of the labels
that then requires translation is
assigned a variable name
that's common across all of the
languages for example x-axis
label the value for this label is then
the text that is the translated string
for example year ano or voicing
in r we then have yaml package to work
with these files
so the strings are read into r using the
function read
underscore yaml as a list of lists
which i then convert into a data frame
within the ggplot code each of the
labels that requires translation
the then substituted with that variable
name
the list of languages that needs to be
generated
is obtained from the first level in the
hierarchy of the yaml file
and then i iterate over those languages
and replace the variable names with each
translated string
as we generate the output for that
translation
the first benefit of this process was
that it allowed us
to give the translators some more custom
control
over the labels what i mean by this is
for example
in some cases we needed some part of the
string to be in italics
for example the units with just
english this is fairly straightforward
to do within the r
script however if we take multiple
languages
into account how do we know which part
of the string
needs to be in italics this is where i
use the gigi text package
this is a line from the theme function
which i showed earlier
where we replaced the element text
function
with element markdown what this enables
is that
the translators can use simple markdown
in their strings
which is then converted to display the
correct output
in the final image so for example they
could
enclose a unit in asterixes and this is
then converted into italics in the final
output
this worked well for labels that will
access titles
however we also have many labels that
require translation
that are placed on the plot with
geomlable or geom text
in order to cater for this what i did
was again use
the gigi text package and create a
function
that corresponds with the original
ggplot to override it
so for example geom text and here we use
instead geom underscore rich text which
again
enables translators to be able to
put simple markdown into their strings
that's then catered for in the final
output
one of the really interesting challenges
to solve with the translation
was the different numbering systems for
different languages
and how do we automatically cater for
this in a single r
script what do i mean by this
well here you can see three graphs in
three different languages
what i want you to do is take note of
the y-axis and the format of each of the
numbers
on the left we have english and you can
see
that the thousand separator is a comma
we then have spanish which has a space
separator
but only once the digit is more than
four
once the number is more than four digits
long
then we have the finish and here you can
see that
thousand separator is a space so how do
we cater for this
in the r script the solution i came up
with
was to create a number formatting
function
per language which uses the number
format function
to specify what the
big mark should be for 1000 separator
and the
decimal mark whether it should be a
comma or a point
the key thing here is that each function
for each language has the same name as
the two letter abbreviated
version in the yaml file
this here shows english compared
to finnish which is denoted by ifi
the spanish was a slightly more involved
example
and function and what i did here was
to iterate over the list of numbers
supplied as the labels
and first check whether the number is
more than four digits long
if so then it gets a space and otherwise
there is no space for the thousand
separator
within the ggplot code within the r
script
each the production of each of the
languages is handled within a for loop
and as mentioned previously this list of
languages
is obtained from the first level heading
in the yaml file for example en
es f5
in the ggplot code i then use the
veryhandymatch.fun
function from base r that takes
the language input as a string
and then uses the number formatting
function that corresponds
with that in order to format the numbers
for the y-axis according to what is
needed for that language
this here shows the y-axis but it can
just as easily be done
for the x-axis figured this last piece
in the puzzle out
for how to automatically translate
images
within our pipeline i then went back to
the publishers
and heard a resounding let's do this
from there
so we are now at a stage in the process
where we are figuring out
how to integrate
with the publishing pipeline in order to
automatically
and beautifully create thousands of
images for their
economics textbook
peeking into our workshop from the
perspective of the publishing industry
what we have done may seem
incomprehensible
but i hope what i've demonstrated here
is that with a few familiar tools
applied in unconventional ways you can
completely transform
a conventional process
there are so many industries and
processes out there
that are still very manual and time
intensive and battling to keep up with
our ever-changing
world they don't know it yet but they
could really benefit from your skills
and from my experience they won't
necessarily come knocking at your door
so sit up and take notes of
opportunities where you can really add
value
for me i'm thinking of those economic
students
sitting in the lecture venue at the
start of the academic year
not only would they have lived through
the previous year however bizarre
and unusual it might have been and come
out different for it
but now the textbook can too
thank you i do look forward to your
thoughts and questions and please do get
in touch
you